WHETHER ARTICLES SHOULD BE
REPORTED TO THE FULL HOUSE.
HERE NOT TO RESPOND, CONGRESSMAN
DOUG COLLINS, RANKING MEMBER OF
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMEN, ARE YOU SATISFIED
WITH THIS ARRANGEMENT?
>> NO.
THIS IS A JOKE.
LET'S BE HONEST WITH THIS.
THIS IS COVERING HER BACKSIDE,
SPEAKER PELOSI SAW 50 SENATORS
SAY THAT THE PROCESS IN THE
HOUSE WAS BAD, THEY DIDN'T WANT
TO EVEN DEAL WITH IT.
SHE WENT BACK TO HIM AND SHE
SAID, OH, MY GOODNESS, WE
BELIEVE THE REPUBLICANS ARE
WRONG, BUT WE ARE GOING TO DO
WHAT THEY SAY.
LOOK, SHE KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT SHE
IS DOING.
SHE KNOWS SHE IS WRONG.
HER COHORT, SCHIFF, DOWN IN THE
DUNGEON, WOW FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NOTICE, AND OTHER TRYING
TO COVER THEIR BACKSIDE.
WITH PROPOSAL THAT IS REALLY
INTERESTING.
THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE THE
PRESIDENT SOME ABILITY TO WEIGH
IN IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
BUT NOTHING UNTIL COMMITTEE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT DUE PROCESS.
AND LET ME JUST SAY SOMETHING.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT RUSSIA, THIS
IS NOT ABOUT A UKRAINIAN PHONE
CALL.
THIS IS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
HILLARY CLINTON WAS CRYING IN
BROOKLYN, 2016, NOVEMBER.
THEY HATE THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
HE HAS DONE WELL AND HE HAS DONE
WHAT HE SAID HE WAS GOING TO DO.
LET'S GET THIS OUT IN THE OPEN,
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
>> Laura: SCHIFF HAS HAD A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST FROM DAY
ONE, HE HAD INITIAL CONTACT WITH
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER THAT WAS NOT
REVEALED IN ANY OTHER LEGAL
PROCEEDING.
HE WOULD'VE HAD TO RECUSE
HIMSELF AFTER FAILING TO
DISCLOSE THAT INTEL, PRESSED
ON THAT.
>> THINK ABOUT WHAT HE DID STOP
TODAY ABOUT THE GENTLEMAN ON
ANSWERING THE QUESTION.
WHO ELSE DID HE TALK TO?
HE STOPPED THAT QUESTION.
WHAT WOULD THAT HAVE LED TO?
WHO DID HE TALK TO?
WAS AT HIS STAFF?
DID SCHIFF ACTUALLY STOP A
QUESTION FROM BEING ANSWERED ON
WHO HE ACTUALLY GAVE THE
INFORMATION TO?
WHICH, IN ADDITION TO WHAT
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN WAS TALKING
ABOUT ABOUT LEAKING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, WOULD IT HAVE LED
TO, TO HAVE ADAM SCHIFF LEAD
THIS KIND OF STAR CHAMBER
INQUIRY WITH NO OVERSIGHT,
NOTHING GOING ON, ONLY
LEAKING WHAT THEY WANT.
THIS MORNING, YOU TALK ABOUT THE
FACT, BOMBSHELLS, THAT WAS AN
OPENING STATEMENT.
IT WAS UNCROSS-EXAMINED
STATEMENT.
THAT IS A RESUME, THE BEST YOU
CAN ON CAPITOL HILL WAS AN
OPENING STATEMENT.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE FACT,
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS TODAY, WE HAVE
FOREIGN POLICY PROFESSIONALS,
SOME WHO ARE ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY, SERVING OUR COUNTRY
PROUDLY, LIKE VINDMAN, BUT
NEVERTHELESS, MIGHT HAVE
DIFFERENT WORLDVIEWS THAN THE
PRESIDENT ON UKRAINE OR VARIOUS
ISSUES.
BUT IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
PIECE YESTERDAY, IT STATED HE
HAS HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS WHO WERE
TRYING TO SOLICIT HIS ADVICE ON
HOW TO WORK AROUND GIULIANI, AND
TYPICALLY THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WERE IN ENGLISH.
NOW, WHAT ABOUT THAT?
I MEAN, THEIR STATUTES, 18 USC
794 INVENTED REFERENCE GATHERING
OR DELIVERING DEFENSE
INFORMATION TO A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT, AND IT COULD BE
IMPLICATED HERE, MIGHT NOT BE
IMPLICATED HERE, BUT THAT IS
KIND OF A WILD THING, RIGHT?
I MEAN, YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
WORKING WITH THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
>> LET'S GO BACK TO THE OPENING
STATEMENT.
HE'S LAYING OUT HIS BEST CASE,
BUT HE GETS INTO THE FACT, HIS
CONCERN ABOUT THE CALL WAS HE
HAD SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
INFORMATION IN THE CALL, BUT HE
SAID THIS COULD HURT US,
POLITICALLY, DOWN THE LINE.
SINCE WHEN IS THAT BECOMING --
>> Laura: AND ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBER IS SUPPOSED TO BE
POLITICALLY CONCERNED, YES OR
NO?
SPEAK I DON'T REMEMBER -- WHEN I
HEARD THE POLITICAL CONCERN,
THAT JOB AS A POLICY.
YOU ARE TO BE THE EXPERT IN THE
ROOM, SO TO SPEAK.
BUT WHEN HE SAID IT WAS
POLITICALLY CONCERNED, THIS IS
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
ADAM SCHIFF IS GIVING LEAKS, AND
WHAT IS AMAZING TO ME IS HE SAID
HE DIDN'T WANT TO ERASE THE
TRANSCRIPT, DIDN'T WANT THEM
OPEN SO THE WITNESSES COULD
COORDINATE.
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING SPECIFIC
LEAKS --
>> Laura: THE LANGUAGE BEING
REPEATED.
>> SO LET'S GET OVER THIS RIGHT
NOW.
>> Laura: YOU AGREE WITH MAMA
SENATE?
THIS HAS TO BE SHUT DOWN, IT'S
RIDICULOUS.
>> I THINK THAT IS WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT.
SPEAKER PELOSI KEEPS THIS
RESOLUTION, SHE IS JUST BEING --
>> EVERYTHING IS TOO LITTLE, TOO
LATE.
WE DON'T NEED ANY WHITE HOUSE
STAFFERS TAKE ON THE CALL.
OH, THERE WAS A WORD THAT WE
WANT TO PUT IN.
WE HAVE A TRANSCRIPT.
WE DON'T NEED YOUR OPINION,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU ARE APPARENTLY TESTIFYING
AGAINST THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
WHOM YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
WORKING, BUT WE DON'T NEED YOUR
OPINION, WE HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
THAT'S WHAT IS GOVERNING HERE,
CORRECT?
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE TRASK IF
THAT IS IMPEACHABLE.
>> THERE IS NOT.
NOTICE WHAT YOU HEAR SCHIFF TALK